elle a grève elle continue donc
aujourd'hui alors pour donner quelques
chiffres mais je peux rentrer trop dans
les détails je passe mes chiffres il y a
si raffineries de pétrole dans
l'Hexagone il y en a 5 qui sont en grève
c'est ça et il y a une usine de ce qu'on
appelle les agro carburants
et donc qui fabrique des carburants à
partir bien sûr de l'huile de palme qui
est situé à La Mède dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône qui est également
arrêté pour fait de grève et il y a
enfin un dépôt pétrolier à Dunkerque qui
dépendent total qui donc lui est un
dépôt d'importation de produits de
gazole et d'essence d'accord et qui est
aussi en grève donc on en est là
aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que la
cinquième raffinerie donc ici elle de
Total énergie de Donges dans le 44 près
de Nantes est en train en grève hier à
l'annonce de Madame borne quand elle a
annoncé qu'elle allait recourir
réquisition donc c'est une mesure on va
dire de solidarité alors qu'ils étaient
pas en grève jusque là combien va dur la
situation combien de temps va durer la
situation bah ça je crois qu'il faudrait
que vous invitiez Monsieur Patrick
pouillané qui est le PDG de Total à
votre émission pour le savoir parce que
nous cette situation est dure depuis le
mois de mars d'accord en mars dernier
parce que effectivement
on n'est pas dans la grève préventive on
a fait des demandes de négociation
d'ouverture négociation sur les salaires
dans le pétrole au vu de l'inflation qui
touche tout le monde et puis bah on a eu
en fait absence de réponse de la part de
la direction on a également donc
organisé une grève de 24 heures au mois
de juin chez Total il y a eu une grève
chez total de 24 heures c'est passé
totalement inaperçu et d'ailleurs on
cherche pas forcément la médiatisation
mais ceci étant on a dit attention là il
faut répondre il y a pas eu d'impact sur
l'approvisionnement il faut répondre aux
demandes qui sont exprimées par les
travailleurs alors vous allez vous dire
les demandes dans un instant total
affirme je termine simplement en disant
que au mois de juillet il y a eu 48
heures de grève on a encore eu une de
nous recevoir et en septembre quand on a
demandé donc là il fallait vraiment
répondre monsieur pouyan et le 27
septembre au lieu de répondre à ça il a
annoncé publiquement qu'il dégageait 2,6
milliards de dividendes supplémentaires
pour les actionner au titre de 2022 donc
on est face à une direction qui est
assez arrogante et aujourd'hui on est
face toujours à un mur d'accord alors
aujourd'hui quand total affirme que les
grévistes gagnent environ 5000 euros par
mois avec les primes vous réagissez
comment et ben c'est totalement faux je
ne sais pas comment ils font leur calcul
j'ai ici dans mon portable une feuille
de paye d'un opérateur de raffinerie
1700 euros qui non non c'est un peu
comment 400400
un opérateur de raffinerie qui a 20 ans
d'ancienneté qui est donc est consoliste
il gagne environ 2900 euros par mois
d'accord alors avec ça donc ils sont
incluses les primes de ce qu'on appelle
les primes de car c'est à dire les
primes de travail de nuit 3 8 24 24 y
compris le jour de Noël et puis les
primes de disponibilité pour les travaux
la dangerosité des travaux etc donc on
est quand même assez loin vous êtes
intéressés
donc on est vraiment sur quelque chose
de spot et le salaire des travailleurs
dans le pétrole et absolument pas ce que
prétend vous êtes plus proche des et
vous êtes plus proche des 5000 euros des
commerces vous êtes plus proche des 5000
euros ah non non moi je suis pas du tout
à 5000 d'ailleurs les travailleurs ils
disent mais quand ils ont entendu la
direction de Total dire ça on abandonne
nos revendications et en fait ce qu'on
veut c'est ce que dit poulet
c'est-à-dire les 5000 balles on les
prend tout de suite on arrête tout
donc aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout ça
non non pas du tout vous gagnez vous
vous êtes à peu près combien moi je suis
à 3000 euros d'accord 3000 euros comme
comme ce que vous nous disiez il y a un
instant 2009 3000 quoi oui oui c'est ça
exactement d'accord et vous êtes vous
souhaiteriez quoi
alors ce qui est demandé alors on parle
le total mais aussi que Sun mobile bien
sûr
mobile vous savez il y a toujours des
grèves là aujourd'hui je sais mais bon
si vous voulez si vous voulez vous
demander 30 % des capacités de la
chanson il y a pas de problème bien sûr
mais total parce que vous je parle vous
vous êtes vous voulez quoi vous voudriez
quoi et ben la demande chez au total
c'est simplement 7 % de rattrapage de
pouvoir d'achat au titre de 2022 parce
que c'est le cas il y a eu 7% de perte
de pouvoir d'achat et 3% donc c'est ces
3% là qui sont demandés pour on va dire
partage des richesses créées par les
travailleurs donc c'est-à-dire ça fait
10 en tout ça fait 10% de de
d'augmentation de salaire 7% de
rattrapage 3% pour cette à 10 % donc
vous vous voudriez environ voilà 300
euros par mois en plus c'est ça d'accord
et donc une prime de reprise aussi
ça c'est pour pour l'instant on visait
qu'est-ce qu'on vous donne pour
l'instant ils ont dit oui il y a quoi à
rien on sait jamais réuni donc pour
l'instant rien en entendant les médias
que il y aurait des premiers avancées
qui seraient à 3,5 % d'augmentation
c'est pour ça c'est ce qu'on entend et
ben ça c'est en fait ça ne commercial ça
ne vient pas d'une réunion de
concertation c'est un chiffre qui a été
envoyé dans les médias ou par Internet
peut-être aux organisations syndicales
chez Total mais en tout cas il y a pas
eu de concertation de négociation comme
on fait les négociations collectives
normalement donc vous si vous avez si
vous avez ces 10%
d'augmentation tour par oui si vous
voulez
ça c'est pas non plus dans la balance
pour l'instant non c'est juste les 10%
et
aujourd'hui on est où ce point mort
alors demain il y a peut-être une
réunion qui est prévue d'accord entre
qui et qui entre la direction et les
organisations syndicales d'accord la
direction totale est-ce que vous pensez
que vous allez pouvoir obtenir ces 10%
parce que c'est 10% négociation on sait
que voilà 100 % exactement donc voilà on
a l'habitude de négocier à la CGT à
cette à 7% ça passera ah bah ça moi
c'est ici que se passe la négo non parce
que il y a le président qui a dit
président a dit que ça allait se régler
semaine prochaine dans le président de
la semaine
de cristal ça m'intéresse donc vous n'y
croyez pas ça il y avait Olivier Véran
qui a dit il y a 15 jours ça va
s'arrêter dans deux trois jours mais
donc non ce qui est plus sérieusement
effectivement ce qu'on attend s'il y a
une réunion demain parce que le problème
quand même c'est que demain enfin du
moins total continue de de subordonner
la réunion de demain à la levée de la
grève mais ça c'est ce qui nous dit
depuis le mois de mars c'est à dire
qu'on ne
négocie pas sous la pression donc c'est
ça donc en fait donc il continue son
arrogance donc en fait le bras de fer il
explique que téléspectateurs c'est vrai
que c'est ça c'est que vous voulez
négocier mais total vous dit on négocie
si vous arrêtez la grève mais vous
voulez pas arrêter la grève tant que
vous n'avez pas négocié donc en fait
c'est voilà le leader donc là demain
vous pensez que ça va être annulé alors
rendez-vous ce qu'on a ce qu'on a je
pense décider de faire en tout cas c'est
les syndicats CGT total qui ont décidé
de faire ça et bien c'est de poser la
question au grévistes donc ce soir parce
qu'il y a des relèves toutes les 8
heures dans les raffineries et bien ils
vont poser la question au grévistes et
bien comment dans les raffineries dans
les dépôts pour savoir ce que
choisissent les gravisses parce que
contrairement
ça veut dire que il y a des grévistes
qui ont peut-être dire nous on y
retourne le temps des négociations c'est
possible d'accord vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup ou pas ça j'en sais rien
par exemple alors non c'est pas des
blocages ce sont des grévistes
parce que Total ne répond pas aux
demandes mais j'entends monsieur et ça
représente combien de personnes
concrètement par exemple au mois de juin
et au mois de juillet il y avait des
grévistes et le pays n'était pas bloqué
vous voyez mais vous voulez jamais
donner le chiffre
plusieurs milliers je ne sais pas
exactement parce que vous savez ça
change tous les jours ça change il y a
des alors il y a les équipes qui
travaillent en 3D continue et puis les
gens qui travaillent à la journée les
gens qui travaillent la journée c'est à
peu près stable mais les équipes qui
travaillent entre les continuent parfois
c'est 100% de grévistes parfois c'est
70% de ma vie parfois c'est 30% de
gravistes alors donc voilà Monsieur
Lépine est-ce que vous comprenez parce
que je vous dis tout ce qui tout ce qui
circule qui est plein de gens là voilà
qui disent c'est pas possible ils sont
extrêmement payés très extrêmement bien
payés nous on touche le SMIC et on fait
pas la grève et qui sont choqués par
votre greffe contenu de vos salaires
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez bah
déjà je pense que il y a beaucoup de
gens aussi qui comprennent ce qu'on est
en train non mais je vous dis aussi donc
effectivement des gens qui qui
comprennent moins bien ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que
pour être opérateur de raffinerie il
faut avoir disons une qualification qui
est quand même assez élevée d'accord
vous imaginez bien pour être simple
opérateur de raffinerie c'est-à-dire
pour rentrer au niveau quasiment du SMIC
parce que dans les les salaires
d'embauche on est presque au SMIC et
bien il faut avoir un bac + 2 et 2 ans
de spécialisation dans des dans des
formations spécialisées donc en fait
quand on gagne alors évidemment quand on
dit 25 100 euros par mois en début de
carrière ou un peu moins quand on
commence puisqu'on est vraiment au SMIC
mais assez rapidement en monte ça paraît
élevé pour un certain nombre de
personnes dans ce pays ce qui est ce qui
est logique mais ceci étant si
aujourd'hui des sociétés comme Total qui
font les milliards que tout le monde
connaît en bénéfice nous disent qu'ils
ne sont pas en capacité de payer leurs
salariés à un niveau de rémunération qui
est relativement élevée et bien qui dans
ce pays va augmenter les salaires dans
quelle boîte est-ce qu'on va avoir des
augmentations de salaire dans ce pays
alors qu'on a une inflation qui galope
oui voilà et donc et puis apparemment
d'après l'Insee c'est pas là de de
s'arrêter en fait ce que à mon avis ne
comprend pas la direction de Total et un
certain nombre y compris le patron c'est
qu'on a un peu changé d'époque on a été
pendant 30 ans dans une période de
relativement stable inflation mais là
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
période qui ressemble aux années 70 où
il y avait des salaires sur les prix et
donc à la limite c'est aussi nous ce
qu'on demande à la CGT de manière au
niveau de la branche c'est d'indexer les
salaires sur les prix de manière à ce
que les salariés ils ne payent pas les
pots cassés de l'inflation vous avez
vous avez vu toutes les images vous avez
vu toutes les images dans les dans les
stations-service vous avez vu également
qui a beaucoup de métiers on a vu des
infirmiers ici voilà qui nous disaient
qu'il pouvait plus exercer leur métier
la police les différentes activités
est-ce que ça vous fait est-ce que ça
vous fait réfléchir c'est est-ce que
vous dites on va aller plus vite on va
essayer de négocier au plus vite bien
sûr alors ça vous fait pas plaisir de de
bloquer des des des compatriotes voilà
bah bien sûr que non mais vous savez je
vais pas faire de faux semblant il y a
nous ça nous touche de faire ça bien
entendu mais ceci étant il y a aussi
là-dedans une responsabilité du
gouvernement on a l'impression qu'il y a
une impréparation très importante du
gouvernement et
un plan vous pouvez pas le reprocher ça
quand même un plan d'approvisionnement
sur les publics prioritaires il est où
le plan d'approvisionnement en 2010 en
2016 c'est les derniers instants où il y
a eu des grandes grèves dans le pétrole
et bien il y avait alors je fais pas de
comparaison entre les gouvernements je
donne pas les mauvais points ou les bons
points mais il y avait eu des
dispositions qui avaient été prises pour
que les ambulances les pompiers la
police et cetera ils sont approvisionnés
dans les stations disons qui étaient
priorisés et aujourd'hui on a rien il y
a ils ont parlé la première ministre t'a
parlé d'une réquisition qu'est-ce qui se
passerait irréquisitionne alors on a
prévenu madame borne la réquisition
c'est une très très mauvaise idée
malheureusement bah parce que d'abord
c'est illégal
parce que c'est parce que s'il a arrêté
si un arrêté préfecture
de pétrole c'est on y pense service
public l'acquisition c'est légal si
c'est une situation d'urgence
d'atteindre à l'ordre public ou à la
sécurité publique
il y a déjà eu des réquisitions dans le
pétrole en 2010 et Sarkozy qu'ils a mis
en place on a fait condamner l'État
français en 2011 les tous les préfets
qui en 2010 avaient pris des
réquisitions étaient condamnés en référé
et c'est ce qu'on est en train de mettre
en place aujourd'hui réquisitions elle
est elle a été prononcée et envoyé aux
salariés d'Ixon mobile à Gravenchon
actuellement en grève d'accord et donc
demain à 8h lors de l'ouverture du
greffe du tribunal des référés et bien
on conteste cette réquisition parce que
on considère que c'est illégal
mais en tout cas on va poser la question
juste et on continue c'est illégal juste
monsieur Lépine la réquisition j'ai
entendu dire dit réquisitionne ça va
être la guerre ça veut dire quoi alors
ça veut dire qu'au-delà que ce soit
illégal c'est une atteinte au droit de
rêve c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
travailleurs qui sont en grève alors
avec des impacts énormes sur
l'approvisionnement le quotidien des
gens on en a bien conscience mais sur le
plan du principe on a des gens qui sont
en grève des travailleurs en grève et
qu'est-ce qu'on est on dit bah vous
venez on va aller j'entendais votre
votre émission de fin disons le siècle
précédent on vient vous chercher le
matin à 6h devant les gosses et les
gendarmes maintenant vous allez
travailler c'est le service du travail
obligatoire ça s'appelle et aujourd'hui
si vous faites ce qu'on est en
démocratie si vous font ça vous faites
quoi et ben si on fait si ils nous font
ça c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire et bien donc premièrement il y a
l'action juridique et puis deuxièmement
ça choque beaucoup de monde dans le
monde du travail et notamment dans les
autres secteurs économiques on a de des
centaines de messages de soutien des
autres fédérations de la CGT notamment
dans l'électricité les ports et docs
tout un tas de de secteurs économiques
qui sont structurants et aujourd'hui il
va y avoir une réaction de toute la CGT
pourquoi parce que on est passé d'un
conflit qui concerne des salaires dans
deux boîtes qui s'appelle total et xon à
un conflit qui concerne des libertés
fondamentales à défendre dans ce pays
c'est-à-dire la liberté du droit de
grève c'est parce que le pays est bloqué
beaucoup de monde
vraiment vous n'êtes pas une société
comme les autres c'est ça le problème
c'est que vous n'êtes pas une société
que moi je suis pour les 35 heures je
suis pour qu'on touche pas au brut et je
suis pour le droit de grève
fondamentalement parce que sinon ce
n'est les portes ouvertes à tout mais
vous n'êtes pas une société comme tout
le monde vous êtes une société alors je
comprends votre combat mais vous nous
annoncez des salaires 2500 3000 euros
par mois des bonus de 6000 euros j'ai
entendu de 6 dollars et là vous êtes en
train de mettre les gens en difficulté
vous parler d'autres sociétés qui ont
aussi rejoignent le mouvement mais
pensez aux électriciens qui veulent
aller travailler qui vont pas d'essence
pensez aux gens qui font confiance
qui prennent 1300 euros composés des
jours parce qu'ils pouvaient pas aller
travailler qui sont enfin on le voit
leur voiture parce que leur voiture est
en fourrière faut payer en plus des
fourrière faut avoir une responsabilité
et là où je suis avec vous le
gouvernement aussi je lui en veux aussi
parce qu'il est 60% sur le gasoil sur un
litre de gasoil il prend 60% donc lui
aussi aurait dû bouger avant quand vous
avez commencé votre première greffe ça
ça s'écorce au mois de juin si je
comprends bien au mois de juin ça c'est
corset là le gouvernement fallait pas
qu'il dorme il a dormi le 27 septembre
il a dormi mais aujourd'hui on est dans
la merde et on est dans la merde avec
des bagarres dans les stations-service
c'est inadmissible et votre comportement
alors c'est votre combat mais prenez en
tête que vous n'êtes pas des gens comme
les autres à 3000 euros net par mois et
garder en tête que vous n'êtes pas une
société comme les autres et je rêverais
vraiment dans un monde que les prochains
contrats qu'on fasse signer aux gens tu
viens chez Total tu viens chez aixon tu
viens chez un groupe pétrolier ou tu vas
dépendre de la vie des Français
j'aimerais bien qu'on leur dise tiens le
stylo par contre en cas de grève tu as
un droit de réserve quand même faudra
aller bosser Si les gens sont en danger
parce que là vous mettez les gens en
danger sur les réseaux
[Applaudissements]
ça fait des années qu'on demande à ce
que c'est ce type d'industrie soit
intégrés dans le service public
c'est-à-dire la nationalisation
pétrolière et ben là je vous souhaite
bon courage
c'est autre chose c'est ce qui s'est
passé au Bataclan
quand je ne peux pas travailler
ça je refuse d'entendre ça le droit
quelque chose de Pacifique quand on
croise les bras parce que on n'est pas
entendu parler des directions on a le
droit de faire ça et si aujourd'hui ça
se passe dans le pétrole qui a intérêt à
faire perdre les salariés du pétrole sur
des questions de salaire aussi simple
que des pourcentages que je vous invite
à coucher
le plus simple pour être franc non mais
moi je suis pas chez Total d'accord
mobile mais ceci étant puisque moi je
représente l'ensemble de des salariés
tout en net pour être clair en brut en
brut c'est du bruit tout ça c'est des
salaires qui sont quand même élevés
c'est des gros mais on en est bien
construit ce sont des salaires qui sont
qui correspondent aux qualifications
faudrait légiférer on vous sortir du
cercle d'une société
et je vous souhaite bon courage pour
[Musique]
que on réponde simplement on se mette
autour de la table pour négocier on sait
bien qu'on va pas obtenir la totalité de
ce qu'on demande mais on veut négocier
et c'est parce que le problème c'est que
si on est dans l'assurance cher la
spirale de de contre-réformes etc enfin
disons de contre-mesure sur la question
de la pénurie que l'on comprend encore
une fois et bien effectivement il y aura
une spirale et les travailleurs
avant la fin de la semaine alors non non
il y aura un temps après c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est que ils sont un peu pas
manipulés mais de concert en tout cas
avec la nupesse pour renforcer la grande
marche la grande rêve de samedi Rousseau
a dit la grève
et on dit que vous êtes
à ce moment-là donc la France sera dans
la merde je comprends revendications
salariale vous avez raison mais bloqué
la France vers chier tout le monde le
vin le 20 septembre a été déclenché
cette grève chez Axson mobile et le 27
chez Étienne des sols syndic
Rousseau je sais pas où elle était le 20
septembre je m'occupe pas de politique
nous on est des syndicalistes on veut on
veut les salaires par contre
effectivement si le politique
c'est-à-dire madame borne se met son
grain de sel là-dedans sans répondre à
ce qu'on demande c'est-à-dire qu'elle
oblige les patrons à se mettre autour de
la table bah effectivement ça va prendre
d'autres proportions mais ça je veux
dire si c'est un engrenage qu'on veut
éviter mais par contre qui va peut-être
se passer j'espère que de toute manière
on baissera pas les bras j'espère qu'on
va l'éviter vous allez nous tenir au
courant et demain on va voir déjà dès
demain s'il y a eu les négociations ici
la réunion a bien eu lieu et on nous
donnerait des nouvelles merci en tout
cas Emmanuel Lépine d'avoir été avec
nous je vous en prie